Don't think about it, don't make that kind of
face  I'm always keeping an eye on his movements
Just in case, it's a crime
,
isn't it?
Well,
did you know that there used to be a guy who looked exactly like this
Hwanhee?
Even if you say you've been alone for a long time That must
be about your father
[music]
It was tough, but
the dreams that were packed around you were many times more difficult than the training
[music]
I had to have friends  But
art was really about to become useless with just a little bit of art
, right?
'
Cause the uncontrollable air has the power to destroy sugar [music] But you can do it [music] I don't want you on
my side
[music]